kim kardashian's single and ready to
mingle i'm like dropping hints that i'm
single and
i don't know how this dating thing works
well it's actually a source that's
dropping hints filling e.t in on how the
beauty mogul's handling life after
ending things with pete davidson and why
her kids aren't too heartbroken about
the breakup you just gotta roll with it
our source says kim's doing surprisingly
well since their split and leaning on
her family for support she's also diving
into work to keep herself busy and keep
her mind off of it i like always being
busy when i'm not busy
that's when i start to get uncomfortable
and get this kim's ready to jump back
into the dating pool our source adds kim
is definitely open to dating again and
her friends and family would love to set
her up and think it's so fun yeah bible
as for how pete's doing well our source
says he's bummed but trying to stay
focused and positive quote he has the
utmost respect for kim her kids and the
family he wants to maintain a healthy
relationship with all of them he's just
super genuine throughout their
relationship the comedian got close to
kim's little ones north saint chicago
and some i text him i wasn't even
thinking like oh my god i'm going to be
in a relationship with him in july a
source told et kim seeing pete be so
great with her kiddos only made her fall
in love with him more pete is has got to
be literally the best human being i've
ever met like the best heart people
always say like oh he's so funny and
it's like has to do with how funny he is
that's like
fourth on my list of why i like him and
it seems spending time with the littlest
west's sparked a revelation for the
former snl star wanting to be a dad my
favorite thing ever which i've yet to
achieve is i want to have a kid uh
that's like my dream it would be so fun
to dress up a little dude like you know
like you saw it's just like i'm so
excited for like that chapter so like
that's kind of what i'm just preparing
for now is trying to be like as good as
a dude and develop and get better so
when that happens it's just easier but
now that things are over between kim and
pete the kids are doing just fine our
source says they enjoyed pete's company
but they aren't bothered by the breakup
especially since they weren't seeing
pete a whole lot near the end he's been
away in australia filming a movie it is
what it is but this won't be the last we
hear of keith yep after getting a
snippet of their romance in season one
of the kardashians i think just that i
never knew you can just be so happy
watching tv series and going to the gym
from someone that i never thought would
even go to the gym fans will see pete
actually filming for the first time in
season two babe yeah do you want to
shower with me really quick
[Music]